that's some of my family members and
myself on a pillow what's up phrase I
have caviar dreams of caviar dreams I've
champagne tastes what is that word
phrase both of those I don't want
champagne is fine but I don't want
everything tastes like champagne and I
would [ __ ] pate to dream about caviar
what hi I'm Erik Selvig II don't know
now you know your life is different now
smash your pad a lot of people are very
weirded out by this game which kind of
weirds me out because we've been playing
merry kill for years why is this game
any different oh the difference in this
game is that there's no murder element
got it the murder element in dictionary
kill is totally funny and totally fun
but the fact that in smash or past
someone doesn't want to have sex with
you and they're going to let you live
your life the exact same way that you're
currently living it that's disgusting
but when someone wants to murder you ha
ha
this one Smasher Passman this one's
ultimately smash past infinite hat trust
me neither one of these games are like
good for us as humans there is so much
judgment that happens in both of these
concepts but it's just strange to me
that this concept is giving judgment as
if it's a brand new thing and this one
that actually talks about ending the
life of people rather than marrying them
or fishing them it's fun although that
aside I want to participate in this tag
game challenge thing that's happening on
YouTube but I don't want to smash her
past my co-workers so instead I thought
it'd be fun to try and recreate the look
of the youtubers that have uploaded some
of the most popular Smasher past videos
because essentially in their videos they
are judging other youtubers or
celebrities by their appearance so I
thought it would be interesting for me
to try to authentically without
judgement recreate their actual
appearance in the video in which they
are judging other people by their
appearance as to whether they would do
sexual intercourse with them ok so I'm
going by general popularity here very
much the most viewed masterpath videos
from Kay
who I've heard of I don't know much
about its content but it was purely made
for entertainment purposes only
I'm not to be taken seriously if you're
easily offended then leave the video now
and go what's up today JJ go to me
okay straight when everyone is making
sure because I'm no fan of misogyny or
women are equal did you go to the B mama
you know what I wish I could have I was
pretty much on the plane okay okay okay
sure there's no misogyny in their video
there is no irony in my video I'm gonna
try and actually recreate exactly what's
happening here first manage to do turn
this couch into a very standard
masculine black leather couch because
that doesn't absorb [ __ ] stains it's a
fact you can wash out come so much
easier from leathers then you can from
fabric so I get why so many males have
leather couches more you know rainbow
let's make this couch a leather couch
pleather cuz I don't I don't have enough
money to own leather I'm not a ksi gamer
you kidding me these are two pleather
dresses I own from Zara whoa DIY
makeover i stuff the Hat was another hat
so it could look more like his hat don't
actually have a black turtleneck which
is weird for me but I'm already wearing
black as a black sock on so very Steve
Jobs made Thanksgiving pilgrims
you didn't have blonde hair shove it in
the hash of it in the Hat no no no it's
not leather it doesn't match my healthy
fortune
the job goes to Coachella okay
and then you've got his friends next to
him okay now we're into the weight it's
not we're gonna press stop judging me
judge women with me I think we did
except wait a minute we haven't done it
yet because we do really [ __ ] all in
jail don't get offended but this is
actually very honestly how we feel off
the women that we're looking at don't
take it seriously but this is seriously
how we get seriously but this is an
obviously human opinion of the women and
school did it ksi Wow Oh
the next Metropass video is a popular
one from zoe burger so let's check this
out a novelist is Hannah mojo oh yeah
she's pretty but then let's do four no
makeup video though oh she look like
that kind of shame right you know let's
go ahead and pull it out actually goes
on YouTube oh I got it to be fair the
girl because she stirred up stuff in the
video over like sickness I know I am
ugly without makeup thank you in advance
for all of your comments so ask your
prom but like kids all be in trouble and
additionally are forming machine hot mix
okay mmm okay let's recreate their look
I only like paint a playing Zoe so I cut
one from a t-shirt and I got a sneaker
with some white laces no way I have to
admire that your name if it's a real
name or fake name I don't know that
you've chosen to spell it in the last
possible choice I would ever use itself
either Zoe or burger also I put a real
problem for the first time in like six
months and now we're just gonna lace us
all there's nothing important thing is
you're everyone to think that your chest
give me your shirt looks very stretched
it can barely be contained
look I got the wrong sure now pigtail
symmetry and sexuality and then I know
that Zoe has bangs and I don't act clip
and bang and I didn't get them for this
video I own these already so there's no
shade here in this video because I'm a
girl that owns clipping back tell mother
figured out okay I'm no burger away but
I needed my Abigail yeah she's fine but
like quickly look up the video of her
with no makeup so I can immediately feel
better about myself
are you awake last masher or passer we
will be recreating his wolfy wrap I
didn't know about until this trend and
what we has done multiple Smasher past
video you ask you parents who they would
have sex with them okay I back with
problem or the most crazy videos I've
got on my channels in the past couple of
years
okay I thought you [ __ ] crazy Oh 200
I'm like on this video I wonder what a
challenge with my parents I want you I
need you guys to go down like when I
threw on a thousand light because it
might end up my dress divorcing
awareness he need to do what happens if
you don't does the bus explint found
both calm Andrea crazy a lot of security
guys I feel with that hundred Eagles
over my view okay let's make a Whoopie
reps look we got to get our leather
couch going again look I did not set out
in this video to say that leather
couches were a stereotype for men but
wait easier to clean come up done okay
now we have hat a black t-shirt and all
the right accessories I don't have a
black hat and got a necklace I got ring
I don't have his watch so I'm gonna
earrings me hearing what's a boy to do
without hearing I don't
hearings like that I have but I have
gold wire ah did it it didn't make us
turn up cycle from previous DIY there we
have it now will be wrapped but wait a
minute will be wraps unless on my
goodness I don't want to do that a you
guys didn't you made me do it because I
specifically asked you to make me do it
I said I didn't want to do this but you
lose made me do it even know who I will
help that you would make me do it good
for you will see is really exhausting
trying to be you well there you go that
was me actually trying to actually
recreate the look of some of the most
popular smashers and passers at this
point in time on YouTube hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did give it a
thumbs up and let me know in the
comments um no what do you would
anything anything I'd rather not be
about smashing her pan I'm going to
click this one here suspect this YouTube
channel if you haven't already because I
don't know I would rather you be dead
then spend the rest of my life with you
or insert genitalia in areas while all
along but this one I'd rather just not
have sex with you and you continue to
like succeed in ways that you've already
been doing